Branches are one of the most important concepts.
In this course, Tobias will give you a thorough
understanding on how branches work in Git. And
don't forget to hit that subscribe button so you
don't miss any of our great courses. Hello Free
Code Camp friends. My name is Tobias and I'm going
to explain how to work with branches in Git. One
of the core and most important topics in Git and
version control is how you can productively
work with your branches and what you can do
to start off. But before we go, let me have a
huge shout out to the people at Free Code Camp
for teaching people how to code for
free on the internet. Thank you so much
for being on that mission. And thank you
for letting me help a little bit with that
contribution. A couple of words about my
background, I'm part of the team behind tower
tower is a graphical user interface for Git on Mac
and Windows. And we've been around for more than
10 years now. And in those 10 years, we've
helped around 100,000 people in companies
big and small freelancers, every developer
in every part of the world, work more easily
with the good version control system, take the
headache out of good and make it more more easy.
This workshop today will not be about tower, don't
worry, you don't have to have tower installed,
we will do everything on the command line. So you
can follow along, no matter what you're using.
So before we start, what's this going to be about?
branches are one of the core concepts in Git. And
there's really an endless amount of things you
can do with them, you can create and delete them,
you can compare, you can merge and rebase them you
can publish and track them. So we're talking about
all of those things that you can do with your
branches. Before we dive into the specifics,
let me just briefly talk about two core
concepts that are mentioned again and again.
So one is the head branch. If you don't know
that term, that's pretty important. It is the
currently active or the checked out branch,
you can have many branches in your repository,
but you can have only one. And that is active at
a single time. So if you hit get status on your
command line or are in a graphical user interface,
you will see you are on a certain branch in this
example here on branch master. So master is
currently the head branch, the active branch.
And the other core concept is the distinction
between local and remote branches.
So when we're working with branches, we are in 99%
of the time or 95% of the time, we're working with
branches in our local Git repository, right?
The remote branches in your GitHub, git lab,
Bitbucket, as your DevOps, whatever you have, that
they're more for synchronizing, right, the bulk of
the actual work happens in your local branches on
your local machine in your local Git repository.
Alright, let's start by creating new branches.
Right. So before you can work with branches, you
will first need to have some in your repository.
And to create a new branch, you can just use the
git branch, command and provide the name of
your branch. So my new branch is the name of
that new branch. And when I do it like that, when
providing just a name to the git branch command,
git will assume that I want to start my new branch
based on the currently checked out revision. So
I'm going to create a new branch on the situation
that I was to this point. So if I'd like to create
a new branch at a specific other revision,
let's say, let's see what revisions we have
in this repository. By the way, so this is this
tower, the graphical user interface that we make.
So here is my new branch, I just created that.
So that worked good news. If I want to create my
branch on a different revision, let's say
I want to start here, I can just copy the
revision hash of that commit here. And then
on the command line, I can type git branch,
other branch, that's the name and I wanted
to start on that revision here. Alright,
let's see what that did. Alright, and new
branch. So that worked. And it started
on that revision here, right? So you're pretty
flexible with how you want to start your branches.
And again, as I mentioned briefly, in that
core concept area just a few seconds ago,
you can only create new branches
in your local repository, right?
Creating branches in a remote repository, happens
by publishing an existing local branch so I can, I
can upload these here, but I can't Create a branch
on a remote, we'll talk about that later on.
Or write git branch, either without
mentioning a specific revision, then it's
going to be your current revision, or mentioning
a specific one to started on a specific revision.
Alright, switching branches, of course, another
very important action you're going to use all of
the time. So the current branch, the checked out
branch, so to say, the head branch, defines the
context your work is in at the moment. And the
current head branches where new commits will be
created, they will be created in that context. And
to change the branch you're currently working in.
This means to check out another branch or to
switch a branch. And let's see how we can do that.
All right, so at the moment, if I hit git
status, I can see I am on branch main. So main is
currently checked out, this is my head branch.
And if I want this to be a different branch,
I can type git checkout. And while we
have so many beautiful new branches,
get new branch. And while I switched to
branch, my new branch, so the git checkout
command is pretty versatile. It's it's used
for so many things. In recent years, there
has been a new command added to the Git command
palette, and I would suggest you use Git switch
in the future. Because Git switch is only for this
purpose. It's only for switching branches. So if
we want to switch to we created other branch, I
can type Git switch, other branch and get switch,
as I said, is a little bit more unambiguous.
Because it only has this purpose. git checkout
is a command with lots and lots of meanings.
So I'm more comfortable using Git switch,
git checkout and get switch again. So you can see
in a graphical user interface, this is where the
head pointer now points to. So other branches,
currently the checked out the active branch.
Okay, number three renaming branches, it's
pretty easy to miss type A branches name or to
change your mind after the fact. So don't
worry, you can rename branches, of course,
and get makes it pretty easy to rename your
local head branch. So let's do that. So
we are currently on. Again, let's type git status
to make sure we are on branch other branch.
And if I'm not happy with that naming, I can
just change it using git branch with the dash
m parameter, and then provide a new name.
So better branch, let's call it like that.
And take a look. Okay, I'm now on branch,
better branch. And that was pretty easy.
So in case you want to rename a different branch,
not the head branch, not the currently checked out
branch, then we have to provide the name of the
old branch to to make this an ambiguous so at the
moment, we have, let's see what branches we have.
We're using git branch without any parameters. All
right, so better branch main and my new branch.
So let's say I want to rename a non head branch,
a branch that is not currently checked out.
Let's say I want to rename my new branch here. So
let's make some room. Alright, so let's rename
git branch, dash m, my new branch and call it
my better branch. Let's see if that work. git
branch without any parameters shows you what
branches you currently have. And voila, we just
changed the name of a non head branch like this.
So these commands are used to work for changing
local branch names. If you'd like to rename a
remote branch, things are a little bit more
complicated because Git doesn't allow you
to rename rogue remote branches really.
So in practice, renaming a remote branch
can be done by deleting the old one and then
pushing up publishing the new one from your
local repository. So let's take another look
at what we have. So if I'm not happy with
origin, staging that naming here, I can delete
that and then re upload it and I'll show you
how to publish upload your brand For the first
time in a second, so we can see how that works.
All right, renaming branches with the git
branch dash M. Command. And if you have
a non head branch that you want to rename,
provide the old name, and then the new name.
This is for renaming remote branches. And we'll do
that in a while we are creating a new branch and
pushing that for the first time. So we can do two
things in one. All right publishing branches. As I
already said, it's not really possible to create a
new branch on a remote repository. What we can do,
however, is republish an existing local branch on
a remote repository. So we can upload what we have
locally to the remote server and thereby share it
with our team, right. So let's see what we have
and what we can publish. Okay, so at the moment,
we have this beautiful feature uploader branch
here, and it's not present on the remote. So let's
say I want to publish that for the first time,
I want to upload it to the remote server named
origin. And let's let's do that on the command
line. So I can just use git push dash u, I'll
explain what the new flag is in a second.
On the Origin remote, and it's the feature, loader
branch. Right, looking good. All right, here we
go. So we've just uploaded that to that branch
here, that local branch to the remote repository.
Now, we'll be talking about this dash you
flag here in great detail in a second. But
to give you the the the nutshell, right now, it
tells Git to establish a tracking connection.
And this means pushing and pulling later on will
be much, much, much, much more easy in the future.
So let's talk about that in detail. Because
the whole topic of tracking branches is really
important to understand. By default, local and
remote branches have nothing to do with each
other, they're stored and managed as independent
objects in Git. But in real life, of course,
local and remote branches often do have a
relationship with each other. For example,
a remote branch is often something like a
counterpart of a local one, right? Such a
relationship can be established in Git. So one
branch typically a remote one, or a local ones,
sorry, contrac. Another one, typically a remote
one. So in this little diagram, here, you can
see we have a local branch, it's called develop,
and we have a remote branch on the origin remote,
that's also called develop, and of course, I
want them to have a relationship with each other,
they're the counterparts of each other. And
with that tracking relationship establish,
when I later pull, or push, when I push from
my local branch or pull from my remote branch,
I can simply use the vanilla Git commands, I can
use git push and get pulled without any further
flags or parameters, because the tracking
connection already knows in the can fill in
the blank. So which branch on which remote do I
want to push to or pull from, for example, all of
that is already saved in the tracking connection.
And we've already used such one way to establish
that so tracking connection when we use git push
with the you option to publish that local branch.
And after that, as I said, we can guess just use
git push without mentioning the remote or the
target branch or the source branch, this all works
out. And this also works the other way around. So
what we did was publish a local branch to a
remote repository. But we can also go ahead and
track or download a remote branch and bring
it to the local repository right the other
way around is also possible. And we can also
establish a tracking connection like that.
So let's see what we have. This would
be number five. And we currently have,
right, a feature login branch on the remote
that is not present here in my local branches.
So let's say somebody else worked on that feature,
log in branch and I want to join that work and
work with that branch. So let's get
that branch to my local branches.
And the way to do that is either to
use git branch with the dash dash track
option. And this will be feature login.
And it's coming from origin feature, login.
So by that I created a local branch called feature
login, that is based on origin feature login.
And they know about each other, right? I
established that tracking connection, and voila,
here we go, we now have that locally. And in
a graphical user interface like tower, I can
see that yes, there is a tracking connection,
right, this local branch tracks the remote one.
Another way to do that, well,
let's create another branch
feature, downloader, so we have another local
branch that is not present on the, on the
remote. And we'll publish that really quickly. And
then remove it from here from my local branches.
Right, so again, we have that situation, I
want to have that feature downloader branch
on my local branches. And currently, it's only
present on the remote. So another way to do that,
instead of git branch dash dash track is
to use the git checkout command. And again,
with the track option, so that's the same. And
I'm basing that on origin feature, downloader.
And by not naming a local branch and just
specifying the base, remote branch, get uses that
branch name for the local branches name, so I now
have feature downloader here again, same thing
as before, so it doesn't really matter if you're
using git branch dash dash track or git checkout
distressed track, it's just another way of doing
that. Okay, tracking branches, very important,
either with git branch, distressed track,
or with git checkout, dash dash track,
pulling and pushing branches. So once you have
your tracking connection set up properly, pulling
and pushing is really simple and almost boring,
actually. So that's why I strongly suggest to
work with the commands I showed you before either.
When publishing a local branch with git push dash,
you are when tracking a remote branch from the
other side with git checkout dash track command,
because again, once this tracking connection
is set up, all you need to do is use Git pull,
and git push to sync your branches, right
get pulled to download new commits from
the remote probably from your colleagues, and
get push for uploading or publishing your own
new work to the remote server. You don't need with
the striking connection setup, you didn't need any
additional parameters, you don't need to specify
the remote like origin and the base branch or
the target branch and the source branch. Just get
pulled and get push is enough. So that's the real
advantage of using those tracking connections.
Let's take another look at what we have here.
and see what's happening. Okay, so currently we
are on the feature login branch. And the Another
advantage of having those tracking connections
set up is that Git tells me if my local branch
and the tract remote branch diverge. And that
means that let's take another look at tower
and what what this looks like. So this feature
login branch here has little numbers here. And
this means one commit hasn't been pushed
yet. So the remote version of that branch
doesn't have one commit that I produced locally.
And the other way around. Two commits are present
on the remote end to probably a co worker or
a teammate made some commits. And I haven't
pulled those down. I haven't downloaded those. So
this is really interesting to stay on track and
understand how local and remote branches
diverged if there's something that I forgot
to push or haven't pushed yet. Or if there's
something that I need to pull I need to update.
And with the command line with the git branch,
dash v command, I can get the same information.
So I see feature logging is ahead one
behind two ahead means I have Local commit
that is not pushed yet behind means I am
behind the remote. So there are new commits on the
remote that I haven't pulled. Pretty interesting
information to understand where you are, how
you act, how current your data is, you could say
how right deleting branches soap, most
branches are not meant to live forever.
And I encourage you to do a little bit of
housecleaning now and then. And here's how
to delete a local branch. That's pretty easy. So
let's move to number seven. And see what we have.
Okay, feature uploader and main are there. The
first thing you know to know is you cannot delete
the current head branch. So if I were to
type git branch, dash D and feature uploader,
I would get an error message because I as I said,
I can delete the branches currently active that
is currently head. So first, I would have to
step away from that get switch main make main or
another branch active. And then I could use git
branch dash D, and feature uploader to do that
loader and deleted branch
feature uploader. So this is now
gone, right, I deleted that. In some cases,
you will again, get an error message. Because
let's say you have worked on a local feature
branch for some time produced some commits,
and then understand, okay, this, this doesn't
lead anywhere I need to delete that you've
produced new commits that are present nowhere
else. And if you try to delete that branch,
git will say, well, be careful, you are
about to delete data that is present
nowhere else these commits haven't
been integrated into other branches.
So are you really sure and that's when you need to
use the dash f option force to force the deletion.
Needless to say, I guess that this is quite a
destructive action with dash F for force. So
be careful you have a hard time getting
those commits back. You can Don't worry, but
it's it has its reasons why good warns you Well,
these commits are present, nowhere else are
you sure you want to delete that branch.
Another thing you might want to do is delete a
remote branch. And as you already know, working
with branches on the local end is different than
working on the remote. So it's a different command
git branch. Let's see what we have first. So
let's say we want to delete that origin feature
downloader branch here on the remote. And we can
do that using Git. clear up a little bit git push
again, and I want to remove something from origin.
Delete flag is used here for feature down loader.
And let's see, all right, boom, there it is gone.
So maybe another important thing to remember is
when deleting a branch doesn't matter if it's
a remote one of our local one, keep in mind to
check if you should delete its counterpart branch
to write the tracking branch. So for example,
if you've deleted a remote feature branch, it
might make sense to also delete its local tracking
branch. That way you make sure you aren't left
with lots of obsolete branches and a messy Git
repository, of course. So always keep in mind when
I delete one branch, is there a counterpart branch
on the other end, either local or remote?
And should I delete that too? Maybe. Okay,
deleting on the remote with git push, and
dash, dash, delete. Merging branches are
pretty interesting topic. Merging is probably
the most common way to integrate changes. So
essentially, you're bringing new commits from
another branch into your current head branch.
That's always the direction, right? You're, you're
integrating into your current local head branch
from another branch. And merging in most cases
is very easy in in in Git and very simple,
different to other version control systems.
So that's one reason why it's so popular.
And essentially, it just requires two
steps. So first, you need to make active,
the branch that you want to have the changes come
into that should receive the changes then execute,
execute the merge command with the name of the
branch that has the desire changes on let's see
what we have here in our example scenario.
Okay, so at the moment Maine has a new commit that
is this one here, title of error page corrected.
And uploader has also a different commit clarify
CSS background rule. So they diverged. And let's
say I want to integrate this commit here or
these changes the new commits on feature upload
into main, right, I want to bring the new
changes into the main branch, then I can just
switch to main, make main active, and then just
type Git merge feature, what was it uploader?
And voila, I'm getting an editor with a why
is that, because merging most often not always
produces a merge commit, right? Think of that
like a knot that combines or that connects two
branches. And this is a new commit. So I
can provide a new commit message. And I'm
going with what Git provides here as a standard
merge branch feature uploader. Just close that.
And let's see what happened. on Main wall,
I just combined these two branches and,
and I have all of the changes
here from both branches.
So this is what the end result looks like. As
I said, there is this merge commit here that
combines the changes from both branches. And
there is another way of integrating changes,
and that is rebasing, so this is just an
alternative way to integrate commits from
one branch into another. And it's very important
to stress that this is not better or worse,
this is not the the pro version and merges
the beginner version, it's simply different.
If and when you're using rebase, mainly
comes down to your personal preferences
and conventions in your team and the situation.
So some teams love rebase, some prefer merge,
and some do in some cases and not in other
cases. So it's not a matter of better or worse,
that's important to understand. So let's compare
merge and rebase. So you understand what's
the difference. So this is the the starting
situation, we have two branches, we have branch a
and branch B, and both have diverting changes
are different changes. So we've couple commits
here and one commit here. And they they
were branched off on this point here.
Now with merge, you've already seen that we would
receive this merge commit in the end this melting
point or this not that combines these two commits,
using rebase. On the other hand, the end result
will look quite different. So especially because
there is no separate merge commit that will be
created this big difference. Using rebase. It
appears as if development history had happened in
a straight line. There's not this, this branching
out anymore, it happens, or it looks like it was a
straight line. And this has its pros and its cons.
So but that's the result and the big difference.
And then starting the actual process is
pretty simple. But let's do that in practice.
This is case number nine. And let's see what we
have. Alright, so pretty similar situation like
before, on feature uploader, I have two commits
these here that are present nowhere else. And on
Main I have this year that is present
nowhere else. And let's say I would
like to integrate the changes from Maine
into my feature uploader branch, right.
So the first step would be to switch to feature
uploader to make that the head branch because,
as with merge, I am always integrating into my
head branch. Right, the head branch is the one
that's being manipulated. I am already on
feature uploader. So nothing to do here.
But the second step is Git rebase. And I want to
rebase on Main. And that was already it. Let's see
what happened. Now you can see this title of error
page corrected commit that used to be on Main
is now also present here on uploader. And as you
can see, there's not this branching out this,
this melting, not no merge commit. This looks like
a straight line. And that's the big difference
between merge and rebase. Again, if you're
using a graphical user interface like tower,
you can just drag and drop to merge or if you
keep the Alt key pressed it becomes rebase.
So these actions are pretty straightforward
in a graphical user interface.
Alright, and so this is rebasing
again, and final case or final action,
comparing branches, sometimes it's pretty helpful
to compare two branches. So for example, before
you decide to integrate or delete a branch, you
want to see how it differs from another branch.
Does it contain any new commits? Or not? Do I
still need those? What's the difference? So let's
do this in practice. And see what we have.
So similar situation should just before
feature uploader and main they diverged, they have
different commits. And let's compare that and see
what is actually different between them. So I can
type git log main double dot feature uploader. And
this shows me which commits are in our feature
uploaded branch, but not in our main branch.
And thereby I can see, okay, these two commits are
here, but not here. And this would also of course,
mean, if I integrated into main these two
commits, would make it into the integration.
So I can understand the
difference between those two.
If I want to see what's the difference between
a local and a remote branch, I can also do that
same thing, actually. So let's compare my local
Maine with the origin Maine. And the process is
pretty similar. git log, Maine. Let's start with
origin Maine, and Maine. And I can see okay,
I have one commit currently in my local main that
is not present in my remote branch origin main.
So I know. Okay, if I pushed now, I would upload
this commit here because it isn't present there.
All right. I think this is it for today. To help
you remember what you learned, I prepared a little
cheat sheet about this topics about all of
the different commands that you can use in
regard to working with branches. Just hop on Bitly
and get branch's cheat sheet and download that
for free. This comes in handy in your daily
work, I'm sure of it. And you can download
the cheat sheet for free as you like. I hope
there's a little bit of new information for you
here in this workshop and in the cheat sheet.
Have fun creating deleting renaming, tracking,
pushing, pulling, comparing branches and work
with Git. Thanks for your attention. Take care.